enrico ciccone député libéral de
marquette anciens joueurs la ligue
nationale bien sûr j'en avais reçu et
donner des coups vous et on le sait
depuis quelques temps vous militez pour
qu'on met les freins sur cette violence
gratuite d'abord votre diagnostic
d'hyères soit au revoir les images
est ce que pour vous c'est intentionnel
schifferli voulait faire mal mais
c'était une première à bord soir 3 1
c'était d'une violence vraiment inouïe
là on voit sharif leckie qui est
pratiquement la longueur de la patinoire
pour mieux appliqué une mise en échec et
je connais très bien par maurice j'ai
entendu ces propos peu plus tôt je lui
comme entraîneur également c'est un
entraîneur qui valorisait les le jeu
physique finir six mises en échec passer
des messages pour le prochain match est
évidemment quand on est assez résigne à
thoiry qu'on jouait à répétition contre
la même équipe on veut passer des
messages de la sent cependant j'avais
aucune référence là avec cette mise en
échec leurs 18 heures d'analysé works et
j'ai une carrière de dix ans dans la
lignée celle également j'étais suspendu
aussi est vraiment c'est un coût qui
était sans précédent parce que ce genre
d'assaut dans la glace libre où le
joueur se retrouve pas dans la bande et
on va d'abord prendre une décision et
qui est vraiment là un précédent une
jurisprudence prix capables de se fier
sur ce genre de curieux pour pour le
futur vous êtes enrico pace sans
précédent pour vous que ce que ce ce
coup là parce qu'ils n'étaient pas prêts
de la barre par à cause de la vitesse
mais il visait il ya quelque chose que
vous n'avez jamais vu même effectivement
quand on voit ce genre de dassault des
pénalités des sceaux il ya un an durant
la saison il ya un an pendant les
matches on le voit pas de façon
régulière mais on le voit mais souvent
la joie va se retrouver dans la baronne
souvent le joueur également pas être
frappés directement la taille ou le
joueur l'a fait dans l'angle mort mais
de cette façon on off face à face
vraiment alors avec une force
gigantesque
c'est très rare puis j'en demandais
juste
la décision qu'on va prendre du côté de
george parros qui le préfet de
discipline de la ligue nationale
comment va prendre cette décision là
parce qu'elle s'annonce on retourne
toujours en arrière on va voir le genre
de pénalité suspension qu'on a donnée
mais cette fois ci la jemmerais poste et
dans les souliers de jack sparrow
cg communiquer avec des gens qui sont
très près la ligne savall aujourd'hui on
me dit qu'on mettait énormément de
pression sur georges perros pour qu'ils
donnent le maximum qu'ils soient de cinq
partis et ils vous cinq parties est ce
que ce serait à vos yeux suffisant vous
auriez demandé encore plus pour toutes
les séries moi j'aurais demandé plus
parce que justement pour faut prévoir
s'il faut travailler en amont on ne vit
hier sur la glace là que les legends
première ligne zerbib qui ont été là
pendant le match qui on l'a vu pendant
le match j'ai regardé ce match là et on
voit que cha et flic et un joueur étoile
dans la ligne ça va très bon joueur qui
n'est pas habitué à ce genre de geste là
on voyait qu'il ya la mène et du tapage
vous me permettez l'expression qui
traversait la ligne de tram aurait pu
avoir quelques avertissements de larbi
mais on l'a pas fait alors on n'a pas
protégé les abbés sont là pour protéger
les joueurs sur la glace et c'est le
résultat qu'on a vu justement hier pour
passer justement un message de riquet
quitté déplorable mais s'intéresse à ce
que vous dites vous que l'entraîneur
c'est comme s'ils avaient demandé à ses
joueurs
montrer aux canadiens qu'on est on prêt
dur puis laissez passer des messages
cette culture leur écot qui connaît
aucun elle va elle va disparaître mais
c'est justement je dis pas que
l'entraîneur et ses joueurs pour passer
un message c'est cette culture là on est
programmée de cette façon on est élevé
d'un très jeune âge de cette façon de
également quand on joue un match on dit
parfait foulée ces dates marquent faut
donner le rythme peau pour le prochain
match puis moi aujourd'hui je m'élève
justin côte ces gestes violents de
violence inouïe là notamment chez les
bagarres parce qu'aujourd'hui on ait des
études et des rapports qui ont été
écrits par des médecins des spécialistes
comme lé commotions cérébrales peuvent
mener affectés
une personne à long terme - monsieur
ouais je me lève pas chaque matin et je
me demande avec mes 5 c'est cette
commotion cérébrale est-ce que je vais
commencer à faire la démence que je vais
commencer avant de l'alzheimer
prématurée est ce que moi j'ai des
coéquipiers qui ont passé à l'acte se
sont suicidés depuis qu'on a c'est à nos
partis alors ccc c'est pour ça que je
m'élève contre ce geste lui aujourd'hui
la ligne ça doit passer un message très
clair avec la décision sur une
suspension mais j'entends c'est depuis
hier soir doit doit doit nationale doit
faire si on a l'impression qu'ils le
font pas que il va avoir à peu près je
dis n'importe quoi mais trois matches
maintenant qu'on va passer un autre
appel
mais vous savez pourquoi le savoir parce
que la ligue nationale est là pour
plaire à ses à ses fans ses partisans
ils ont aussi que les partisanes
notamment aux états unis
on aime le jeu physique on veut voir de
la violence on veut voir des bagarres on
a un commissaire qui est un homme
d'affaires c'est pas un sportif l'homme
sûr maintenant c'est pas un homme qui
s'est battu c'est pas un homme qui a été
frappé durement
c'est un homme d'affaires qui doit faire
faire de l'argent au gouvernement et aux
propriétaires
il veut donner aux partys à ce qu'ils
veulent et qu'est-ce qui qu'est-ce qui
est vendeur mais si tu sais monsieur roy
c'est à dire comme ça c'est sévère 6-1
jeudi mais ce qui est vendeur ses 10 ans
à longeur de voir moi ce que la ligue
nationale bonbons répondants le sommet
la culture ça commence puis je vous
remercie de parler ce soir parce que la
sensibilisation l'éducation commence
dans les maisons qui paraît avec avec
nos petits bouts de chou moi ce que je
comprends pas parce que vous étiez un
joueur dont la tâche est entre autres de
faire ça ce que je connais mais hier
vous l'avais dit à plusieurs reprises
une étoile de l'équipe c'est un marquage
sakho qui est un principe fait pour ça
qu est ce qui est arrivé dans sa tête
d'après vous ben je sais pas ce qui est
arrivé je vois que vous appelez ça une
crampe au cerveau le puits c'est
justement pour ça que moi je soumets jeu
mais je vais la garder joie tous les
joueurs qui sont sur la glace de ligue
nationale de toujours se pauvreté j'ai
également parce qu'on sait jamais quand
est ce qu'un excellent délicatesse qu'un
joueur étoile marchand et flipper bonne
trempe au cerveau et servez
coups d'une violence inouïe comme il l'a
fait hier alors c'est à nous également
de bien prendre soin de notre personne
qui connaît député libéral de marquette
anciens joueurs la ligue nationale bien
sûr merci beaucoup nous avoir parlé
merci du roi merci à eux pour voir nos
émissions en entier rendez vous sur la
chaîne ici et redit